hey everybody thank you for stopping by
led
live again we have a great show for you
today because we've been talking
over the last few episodes of a lot of
different devices
addictions possession how do you get
freedom from all this find out on this
episode of
led live
[Music]
light exposing darkness so we hope you
guys have enjoyed a few of the other
episodes that we've
put out with eric wilson thank you for
coming by once again
and i'm excited to dive into this
because you know we've talked a lot
about the problem and i'm ready to hear
for the solution
how do we overcome some of these things
if we get ourselves entangled in this
mess of sin what are some of the steps
we can get out
before we get into that i want to thank
all our viewers thank you for you guys
who have
subscribed to our channel and you're
liking our content or commenting with us
we really do appreciate you in fact many
people have even sent us testimonies
of things that have been said on this
show that have really really made you
think or changed your life we want to
hear
more of those feel free to send them to
us write to us it
encourages the whole team to keep going
and if you guys have any suggestions for
content
we're listening to that as well and uh
if you're new to the channel we've got a
lot of dvds our ministry produces you
can check us out on little
lightstudios.tv
and patreon donors you guys are awesome
we just
love you guys to pieces because you guys
really make all this possible so thank
you for donating to our ministry
so eric wilson how do we how do we begin
to get
freedom from all this because you know
when you get in bondage to sin
it feels hopeless it feels like there's
no way out
and i know that that god is always
giving us a way out
i'm glad you asked that what i
what i want to share today is not um
from book it's from my own experience
and
you know if you want to help somebody
get free from alcohol
sometimes the best person to do that is
someone who's gained victory
growing up in a christian home and
and then walking away from god walking
away from the bible
and you know christianity i always knew
there was a god i mean even when i was
serving the devil i never
doubted that there was a god and i knew
i was going to go to hell
i mean i knew that interesting i can
remember when i was probably 19 years
old i had
probably 40 people at my house drinking
and watching mtv at two o'clock in the
morning and we were yelling and
acting like you know foolishness and
there was a knock on the door
and i'll never forget there was a
one or two maybe three young men there
and they were
high school age and the one looked at me
and he said
i want to share something with you about
the lord jesus christ
and it's like that should have touched
my heart i cursed him out
oh wow not like i was angry i was just
like you've got to be kidding
i mean blah blah blah yelling at him and
and i went back inside and we all
laughed and mocked and
until one night when god woke me up
and i'll never forget that night because
i i had been laying there in bed i was
reading a stephen king novel
i mean it's so funny it's like we can't
read one book in the bible this
stephen king is over 600 pages and i'm
devouring it you know you sit there for
hours reading
this trash and i'm reading this book i'm
halfway through it and finally i'm like
okay it's too late i'm just going to go
to bed
and i went to bed and
i just i mean i felt deep sleep and all
of a sudden
in the sleep i saw this huge
screen like the one behind us i mean it
was like a huge tv
you have to remember this was back a
little while a couple years ago
so here's this big screen tv
and i saw all these things that were
happening
in the world interesting i mean i saw
like you know the war i remember in
desert storm
i mean i know that's telling my age but
you know the war in iraq and i'm
watching this and i'm seeing the riots
and i'm seeing
the stock market i'm seeing the economy
collapse i'm seeing
race car you know track i'm just seeing
everything that's happening in the world
and then i started noticing that i
recognized some of the people
in the scenes that were flashing up on
that screen
and then i saw myself
and the people that i knew and that i my
family and friends and people that i
interacted with you know at the grocery
store
and i saw how i treated
others and it was like it got
it got very quiet and all of a sudden
the only thing that i heard
in that entire dream i saw a hand reach
up and it was like it pulled the plug
out of the wall
for the television and then have you
ever and i know some of y'all may not
remember this but back
um when i was younger television
stations only ran
until a certain time at night and then
you'd go to white screen they called it
snow
it looks sort of like some of the ones
behind us i don't think i remember any
of that
i think since i was a kid i i don't even
remember the tv being off actually
um i didn't grow up with a lot of tv so
that could have easily happened and i
just did yeah
well it was like he unplugged this hand
unplugged the screen from the wall
and the tv went sh just like these ones
behind us
and then i heard a voice the only voice
that i heard
and it said this is your last chance
that was
it and i woke up i mean in that moment i
woke up and
i was covered in sweat the whole bed was
you know just sweat and i looked over at
the clock and it's like it was flashing
like it had been unplugged
3 a.m and
i knew i mean there was no doubt i mean
i
knew i knew who it was that had spoken
to me
and i mean i fell down on my knees and i
was like god i don't even know where to
start it's been so long since i've even
talked to you or
opened my bible that was a joke
and i said i give everything to you i
said help me
i said please save me don't give up on
me
so the reason i'm sharing this is
because
a lot of times we as christians
i think how to put this the question
came to my mind because i was taught
by a lot of christians and a lot of
times when i went to church
that salvation was sort of like um
an evolutionary process it took the rest
of your life
and you knew you were saved when the you
know the the doors of heaven were opened
to you
finally and i was like
i can't i mean i can't do this i can't
like
make myself better or wash myself or
circumcised my own heart and i was like
the lord just helped reveal to me is
salvation
creation or is it evolution if it takes
me a lifetime
to fix you that's evolution right i
don't
serve an evolutionary god right he spoke
and things reacted to that in existence
immediately
immediately he said let there be light
and it was that moment it was
and i was like god i i can't handle an
evolutionary process i mean i'm already
in my 20s
and life was you know in my mind i was
like it wasn't good
so what we want to look at is how do you
get free
i mean does god put you on probation for
six months or
12 months you know is there something
simple
that we're missing
i want to open with this verse in
jeremiah chapter 13
thus saith the lord i have seen
your adulteries and your names
the word names is like what a mule or a
horse would do
when it's in heat god is saying that's
you guys
and this isn't just talking about
immoral sin
he's saying every time you cheat on me
that's
adultery that's fornication he said so
i've seen your adulteries i've seen you
acting like you're an animal in heat and
the lewdness of your whoredom
and i've seen your abominations on the
hills and in the fields
and then he says woe unto thee o
jerusalem
wilt thou not be made clean it's like
god is right there
offering us salvation and we're like
turning away our ear acting like we
can't hear him or
are we refusing to allow him to do what
he desperately wants to do to
to help us time does not
wash away sins how many people have ever
thought that i mean we all have it's
like
well you know maybe god will forget and
then i'm messed up and you feel
guilty and you feel ashamed and then
you're like
you go to open your bible the next
morning you're like he's not gonna even
hear me
i mean after what i did yesterday or
last night there's no way
i can expect him to hear me and then
we're like oh you know what
i'll just go for a month if i can just
go for a month you know
he'll forget about it he's got all this
other stuff going on
time will cleanse me but time doesn't
wash sins away
maybe if i can just be good enough for a
set period of time
and prove to god that i really am sorry
and that i really have changed then god
will accept
me and love me again has that ever went
through your all's heads
and you know it doesn't matter how big
the sin is i mean like you know for
for the most righteous person in the
church it can be something tiny to us
but we still go through that the enemy
is telling us god doesn't love you
because of what you did
but the bible says that god loved us so
much that he sent
christ while we hated him christ
died for us wow
that's how he could be on the cross and
pray for the people that are nailing him
to the cross you know
it's like he just saw through whatever
was happening to him
and just realized we're all caught in
sin you know
he had compassion on us it's beautiful
you know it it
it amazes me and i don't want to go into
a whole bunch of my past
but i was a wretched
wicked human being and
sometimes the lord i've caught myself i
mean even while in ministry there's
times where i've caught myself
looking at somebody else and thinking
man they are so far gone
and you know what god will say to me
he'll say
where were you eric do you remember the
morning after
you had fallen to whatever sin
and you got on your knees and asked me
to to talk to you
and i came i came and talked to you
after the night before
you were doing something that makes me
want to vomit
and i was like and god was like show
them the same love
show that person the same consideration
because if it wasn't for the grace of
god we'd all be like
the worst reprobate in the world
this is one of my favorite verses too
job chapter 14 verse 4
thus saith the lord who can bring
a clean thing out of an unclean not
one it's almost like at mount sinai
you know the lord is there and he's
proclaiming his law
you know to all the million and a half
or more children of israel
and he gets done you know giving these
commands and you know what they said
everything the lord has said we will do
and you know god was like oh man this is
going to be a long 40 years
because they can't do it and i'll give
you an example
i have been i've had people share with
me i know that their intentions were
good but they're like
christ is our example we have to follow
his example
and i was like okay that makes sense and
you know i'm 51
now probably for the first 38 or 40
years i tried that
i literally i was like everything you've
said god i'm gonna do it
and then you fall and you're like oh god
i'm really sorry i won't do that again
you know
and then you catch yourself a month or
two or three months later and you're
like
i cannot believe i did that again and
you're like man when
that's why people leave the church
they're like this doesn't work
so we we have been told sometimes christ
is our example
you see what he's doing do it
and the lord i was really praying about
that and one day he
he showed me a parable
i can remember when my little boy was
little i mean he's 21 now and taller
than me
um but i can remember when he was eight
years old
and i saw this picture of me out in the
backyard and i've got a wheelbarrow
i've got a pallet full of 50 pound or 80
pound concrete sacks
on the palate and they all have to be
moved to the other side of the yard
where we're gonna
do some type of a wall or something so
i'm out there and i'm getting ready to
do this and my little boy comes out and
you know how little boys are they're
like
daddy daddy daddy can i help you and i'm
like well
yeah this is this would be a good
experience for him i'm like well son
let me show you how to do it first so i
pick up this 50 or 80 pound pack of
concrete
put it in the wheelbarrow pick the wheel
barrel up and i wheel it across the yard
take the concrete out and i bring it
back and i say you see how i did that
he says yes or i say do thou likewise
i showed him how it's done and i go i'll
be back in a couple hours and check on
you
so i go inside and about 30 45 minutes
later i'm like you know i just need to
check and see how he's doing
i stick my head out you know look out
the window
and there's this little boy sitting on
the ground with his hands like this
and there's tears just running down his
face the wheelbarrow's tipped over
there's three bags of concrete that are
broken open on the ground
and i'm like and this is how we have
been
shown god what's wrong with you
look at this you made a mess i showed
you how to do it why can't you do it
and then he's just crying more and
that's how
satan wants us to view our father in
heaven
he did not need an example of how to do
it
he needed an example of surrender and
faith that's the example that christ
showed
because christ said i do nothing of
myself
that's the example it was god he said in
john chapter 14 that was in him doing
the works
and that's even what nicodemus said he
said we
know you're from god because no man can
do the miracles that we see
except god be with him and the word with
can actually be
in god was in christ
that's what he wanted us to see so
all of a sudden it's like my little boy
may want to pick up that
he can't even get his hands on the
wheelbarrow much less get it
or pick up that's god saying i want you
to live a holy life and we're like
we'll do it a few of the people
understood that moses and those that
were holy
they surrendered and they said i can do
nothing without you
and god came in them and empowered them
to do
that's what god wants all right
you guys are being too quiet
in jeremiah chapter 13 the lord tells us
again he says can the ethiopian
change his skin or can the leopard
change his spots
then may ye also do good which are
accustomed
to do evil so he's literally saying
eric you're a white guy i can't i'll
pick on my son again
he used to always tell me when he was
young daddy i want to be a black man
and i was like okay why he was like
because they're the best at sports
they're the best at football they're the
best at basketball
they can run faster and i was like
connor
i said that is so prejudiced yeah i said
you know if god has gifted them with
athletic ability which a lot of them
he has a lot of our brothers and sisters
you know african-americans
he has gifted them but my son is like
you know you can go have surgery you can
do whatever you want to do but you're
not going to be a black man
you weren't made to be one and the same
way
god is saying a leopard cannot get rid
of the spots by trying
neither can you learn to do good
by trying there has to be a new heart
put inside of you
now i think that's an absolute message
of hope obviously
because there is that just stumble and
fall get up stumble fall
get up and every time you do that that
the
the shame of like you know i've done
this so many times and i'm still in the
same place
i'm still having this struggle or still
having this temptation or whatever
and and and that defeat can actually
like
really keep you in that state but it's
beautiful how god is just like listen
it's not it's not you that's gonna do it
you know
he just needs us to surrender that's
right right
because when we surrender and that you
know when the bible tells us in
colossians 1 27 is christ in us the hope
of glory
that's not a metaphor right that's
literal
and i never understood that until i
understood what it was like to have an
evil spirit come in
every one of us that's heard stories
real life stories about there was some
woman that she's 130 pounds and
obviously she was possessed
and took five guys to hold her down that
weigh over 200 pounds
there's no way a 130 pound woman can
fight off five men
unless something else is inside her
strengthening her
but god says that's what i want to do
but you've got to let me in you can't
just take the book
knowledge you've got to let the living
word
the living jesus christ come into his
temple
and reign and that changes everything
that's why ezekiel 36 i don't know if
you're going to bring that verse
no no but that's a good one it's a
really great verse to really illustrate
the concept that
you know i will you know give you a new
heart and i will cause you to walk in my
judgments and you will keep my statutes
like
that's that's god putting his spirit
inside of us and he causes us to do that
that's not that's not
saying well if you just try hard enough
or you just do this
you're gonna do it it's simply opening
your heart to christ
and saying i can do nothing outside of
you
you have permission inside of my heart
you come and do the changing
and he comes in and causes you to walk
in those ways
and the one thing just so that people
don't think well man you've left nothing
for man to do i mean we can just sit
back
for sure the hardest thing to do two
things
is surrender and believe
you have to yield your will and and the
will is sort of like
the steering wheel on the car um
it's what controls the whole car the
will
so there's times in my life where i've
been like
man i want to do this and i know i
shouldn't
and there's a battle going on but i'm
realizing
that the only thing that causes the
battle or allows that battle to stay
is selfishness me wanting to do what
pleases me
the moment i just say christ you know
this battle because he
when he was tempted in all points like
us it wasn't like
appetite it was just generic temptation
okay i won that one
no he took eric's battle with appetite
he took eric's battle with alcohol he
took
your battle with bitterness or rejection
or lust or whatever it was
he took your personal sin
and overcame it so when god promises us
a new heart that heart is christ
christ was like i already conquered your
sin so why
paul says in romans 6 he says sin
doesn't have dominion over you
do you know what the word dominion means
like power over you
yeah ruler he's not your slave master
anymore
that means stand up and walk and it's
like
but we don't believe that it's so simple
it's like god's spoken something
he spoke the universe into existence but
yet he says you're free
walk like it and we're like yeah but i
don't feel free right
right you know when we consider just the
faith
aspect of this like you know god you go
back all the way to the beginning
creation of the world and he's speaking
things into existence
and when god speaks bam worlds or stars
or
fish or whatever are are developed right
amen
then you you think of the story of jesus
when he was on the boat with the
disciples
and you know you've got this raging
storm he's sleeping i mean i i just
think that's
so awesome that jesus he's so peacefully
connected to god it doesn't matter if
the storm's crashing around him he could
take a nap
and then he stands up and he's like you
know uh
peace be still to the wind and the waves
and the bible actually uses a word right
there
it says immediately it ceased
amen so when god speaks something
immediately something happens
right so it's so interesting we have all
of these i mean when he healed people in
the bible right
he immediately that hour like when he
healed the servant
of the of the um roman soldier right um
immediately that hour when this when the
roman soldier went back
they asked him what time was it that you
said that and the second that jesus said
it that happened there was no amount of
time
that was that was after that any of the
healings you are clean
bam they're clean so we've got these
examples of god
speaking and something happening and he
makes all these promises that i can make
you clean
do we actually believe that that's the
point that i believe is
is difficult for people to to really
wrap their head around
right keith did you have something i did
i had it pulled up now
and i want to look up something else i
gotta pull it back up here yeah it's in
matthew
chapter 11. it's an interesting way that
jesus puts this he says come to me
all you who are labor entertainment
which is
is a pretty good description of humanity
yeah
we're weighed down by sin we have all
these problems
and we're we're struggling we're
laboring
to get free right and so then he puts it
in this context he says
take my yoke boy yoke is for oxen
and a yoke is for two
right says learn from me for i am gentle
in the lionheart you will find
rest for your souls for my yoke is easy
my burden is light well
if he's coming to you and says okay you
need this yoke
now rest the implication is
you're still moving well how are you
resting
under that yoke and now it's light and
easy it's because he's the one doing the
pulling
amen amen amen
amen i just thought this illustration
regarding the first
uh who can bring a clean things out of
an unclean things just imagine a glass
of water of mineral water
and then our scene is like a black ink
and
a try with our own ability to separate
the ink and the water right we can't do
it so we need another
mineral water to be poured in it to be
able to make it clean again
right that's right i've seen examples of
that how yeah they dump
a solution i don't remember what it is
you were a chemist what was the two
chemicals that you dumped together that
you can make it clear again
boy what's that that's like was it like
pneumonia yeah or something like that
experiment
yeah you pour one in and it makes it
cloudy you pour it in another and it
makes it
look clear again yeah do you know what's
interesting in
romans chapter 4 it actually tells us
something to this
it says speaking of abraham and about
how it's faith
it doesn't do away with righteousness or
obedience but it means
by faith he comes in and does it
it says as it is written i have made
thee
speaking of abraham a father of many
nations
before him whom he believed
even god who quickeneth the dead
and calleth those things which be not as
though they already
are so god looked out in the very
beginning and everything was black
and he said this will never do let there
be
light boom there was light he looked
into
a man with leprosy and said be thou
clean
immediately he was cleansed he looks
into
somebody who is filthy in sin and he
says be thou
righteous he speaks
righteousness it says in isaiah 45 and
63.
keith i was going to say just the
simplicity of the gospel
really tells us how it all works because
the bible tells us jesus christ came
into this world
to save sinners amen right and paul says
of whom i am chief
if we could fix it we wouldn't need
jesus
that's a good point right so he's not
saying okay i've come
now do it on your own he says no i've
come
and i'm here to rescue you i'm here to
save you that implies
he's the one doing the rescuing he's the
one doing the saving
because we can't do it he who is able to
keep thee
from falling right and present you
faultless before the presence of his
glory with exceeding joy
goes right along with that it isn't
you're the one that's keeping from
falling it's
he's the one that's able to keep you
from falling
and do you know what's weird if it's god
that works in us both to will and to do
what pleases him that's exactly what
satan does
these actors and actresses these
musicians that we've been talking about
they literally say i get down on my
knees and i open myself
up to the spirit world and i say come
into me
and do this acting or do this song or
or do these martial arts and when we do
that
they come in and they do the part the
evil spirits do
so how much more would god not come in
and do
exceeding abundantly more than we could
ask or imagine you know you bring up a
really good point that i've actually
never considered before
i have seen countless interviews with
musicians
that have literally said a week ago i
could not play
and then i let this spirit in and
they're upstairs on the stage
jamming and just going on and everybody
goes yeah that's so awesome
right because they were able to do
something but it really wasn't them that
was doing it it was that
spirit that was inside of them so it's
easy for us to see that on a pop culture
level
why can't we apply that to god even more
amen and that
if we could take hold of that
and believe it and and the word believe
in hebrew is an action
it's not up here alone
is that the word it means it means that
that
because they believed there was an
action that followed that
it wasn't just a simple belief like yes
i believe that jesus is real
devils believe that jesus is real they
know he's real they called him jesus
oh son of the most high you know like
they spoke that when they were getting
thrown out of the demoniac so it's just
knowing who he is
does not merit you for eternal life but
even their belief has action
because it says even the devils believe
and tremble
that's a good point it's true so and
they're working
against him because they believe
so and there's action associated with
that if any of you've seen that film
facing the giants um it was a powerful
story
you know there were some things in it
that maybe i saw a little bit different
but it was a powerful christian
story i never forget that scene where it
showed that older man walking down that
school hall
and he was putting his hands on every
single locker praying for
every one of those children he'd been
doing it for years and god did a miracle
and i think you know we need to be doing
that but we have to do it with faith
god you promised you would do this we're
stepping out of the boat
in faith amen lord
purge me with hyssop and i shall be
clean
you wash me and i shall be whiter than
snow
hide thy face from my sins and blot
out all of my iniquities now i want you
to look with me because there's some
things i caught in this when i was
getting this program put together
he said purge me with hyssop hyssop was
what you
use to cleanse leprosy or a leper's
house
because if you had lived it's funny
because in what we're living in right
now it's like you know they're saying
well kovid lasts for
15 days or 21 days on hard surfaces
so take for instance this man had
leprosy it was worse than covet
maybe it was like you know aids that
could be picked up just by touching
surfaces
and when a leper wanted to be clean the
priest was like okay fine you're clean
we see the leprosy's gone praise god but
now we've got to go take care of your
house because otherwise the house has to
be burned
so they would go into the house and take
hyssop and cleanse
the house well king david here is saying
your house my body your temple
is filthy and it's got leprosy i'm
begging you
cleanse me and then he says
hide thy face from my sins and that
caught my attention because
the bible says that the lord laid on
jesus the iniquities of us all
and do you know what the lord did when
jesus was on the cross
he turned his face and christ called out
my god my god why have you forsaken me
if you can think about that jesus never
had one day
in his entire existence that he felt
like his father was
not there i mean he always knew his
father
was happy and and delighted in him
and for the first time in his entire
life he felt what it was like
for god to turn away and it wasn't that
god left christ but he had to look away
from him
because of your sins and my sins you
know we often talk about
the experience from jesus's perspective
that he went through that at the cross
and
you know it was amazing but
as a father i also think of the
experience
of god because if you have the power to
stop it
and yet you don't i mean i would do all
in my power to
literally take whatever pain whatever i
mean for me so
so i look at that and i go you know yes
jesus suffered immensely on that cross
but
also think about what god suffered i
can't imagine even just turning his face
when he had
every amount of power to stop that what
just happened
and that's just like you know i can't
wait to get to heaven and meet these
you know face to face i want to say can
you imagine what it would be like to hug
christ and to hug god yeah wow
ezekiel chapter 33 verse 10 and 11.
and this is what our father in heaven
said to his
son before he came here he was giving
his son
the words to speak to you and i says
therefore
o thou son of man he says therefore
o thou son of man speak unto the house
of israel
and tell them thus you speak saying
if my transgressions and my sins be upon
me
and i am consumed in them how shall i
then live
and listen to what god's answer is say
unto them
that means your name read your name into
the verse
say unto them eric wilson as
i live saith the lord god for the just
shall live by faith and i was like god
because the just shall live by faith
that's the other verse in habakkuk
but it was like when i was reading
ezekiel 33 the lord told me it was like
it came to my mind immediately
how shall we then live the just shall
live
by faith and i thought about it and i
was like
so jesus was carrying the sins
of every human being that has ever lived
i know what i have felt like before when
i've fallen to one sin
and i'm thinking if you took my whole
life that's innumerable
but if you took my life with innumerable
i can't even count them
times 7 billion and that's living today
right what about from the beginning of
the earth right right
christ all of those personal sins were
laid on him
so he's on the cross feeling the guilt
as if he had done it himself and he dies
and then god wakes him up sends the
angel gabriel to wake him up on that
morning of the third day
and jesus never looks back he doesn't
wake up in the morning and go
oh man you know i remember yesterday
what i was do he woke up and it was like
god woke me up we had made a covenant i
told god that if i would bear the sins
god said i'll forgive them
he never looked back so from the day
that god
raised christ from the dead he has been
living
every day by faith that's why it says
we have the faith of jesus
i can say my sins are gone right they
were blotted out on calvary
that's a key little part of that verse
because it's of jesus not
in jesus name i mean like alone like not
that i just believe in jesus but i have
the same faith that jesus experienced
because he's
in me so that means let this mind be in
us which was in him i will
write my laws in their
hearts and then he says and your sins
and your iniquities
i will remember no more and i'm like
i used to think well that's when i get
to heaven it's now
if i confess it to him christ bore it
and god forgives it and he says it's
gone as far as the east is from the west
there is only one thing that can cleanse
the heart from the stain of sin
and that is the blood of our lord and
savior jesus christ
there's only one thing and you know that
that hit me one day because i was like
how i mean honestly i mean i know the
bible says that the blood of jesus
cleanses us from all sin
but how and i know maybe i'm silly but
it's like
that's how my mind thinks i'm like okay
fine it does but
how i want to i need to see a picture
and then the lord showed it to me in
romans chapter 6 verse 10 and 11.
the bible says that the life is in the
blood
when jesus died for us it wasn't just
simply saying i'll take the beating that
eric wilson deserves
god i i grew up with this picture of a
god that was like god is in heaven he's
on his throne he's angry because he just
found out
that eric sinned and he's angry and he's
like
all the angels are afraid to talk to him
you know leave him alone he's upset he's
like
do something about this and he's like
all right there's got to be blood
there's got to be blood or i'm not going
to be happy
i know i'm just going to kill eric i'm
angry at him i can't believe he sinned
i'm going to kill him
and then here comes jesus no no father
please don't kill him
i'll take the beating for him that's how
i grew up seeing god
and it was like so i love jesus but i
really didn't care a whole lot about god
because i didn't think god cared about
me
or god tolerated me on a good day
and on a bad day he would just soon kill
me if it wasn't for the fact that jesus
had stepped in
and that makes you not believe that god
loves you
that's actually how the devil wants you
to see god in a fearful life
do you know that i'm 51 and i spent
almost
40 years in that bondage
and there was no joy there's no freedom
at all peace no peace that's right
when jesus died on the cross romans 6
verse 10 and 11 says in that he died
he died unto sin once
so he had eric wilson's sin my love for
food
or my lust over other women or my
bitterness toward family members he had
my personal sin
and jesus was like oh this is killing
eric
and it's so overwhelming inside of me he
felt what the power of temptation felt
like
and he said father in heaven i choose to
die
rather than yield to eric's sins and the
moment that he did that
because i was in him his victory became
mine
his crucifixion became my crucifixion
his resurrection is my resurrection to
walk
in newness of life it changes everything
that's why the next verse paul says
reckon you
also yourself to be dead indeed unto sin
but alive unto god through jesus christ
reckon it means i don't reckon so it
means
count it as so it's an accounting term
which i know
keith knows about that wrecking it it
means
i'm reckoning out wages today this is
your wages this is yours this
god is like wrecking it you are dead but
you're alive
in christ and that takes faith
now we're going to close with just a
couple of really powerful illustrations
i want you to listen to these words
and i love this book it's a book called
desire of ages if i
if i could only give out one book
besides the bible this would be my book
because this one is
it's breathtaking listen to what it says
on page 8 23
this world is a vast lazar house that
means a place full of the sick and dying
but christ came to heal
the sick and proclaimed deliverance to
the captives of satan
and i know what that's like i mean i've
been sick i know what that's like
but i have to keep going back and saying
god i'm not going to let go of you
because you swore with an oath and you
cannot lie
he came to proclaim deliverance to the
captives of satan
he was in himself both health
and strength and he imparted
his life to the sick
the afflicted and those possessed of
demons when he saw somebody like that
and he said to the demon you've got to
leave and the demon said i'm not going
anywhere
i'm not going anywhere i have every
right to be here they want me here
and jesus is like
but they're asking for freedom and the
devil says yeah but they sinned back
there
and the wages of that sin is death
and christ said well there's only one
way to fix this i'll take eric wilson's
sins
and i'll give him my life what right do
you have to be there now
the devil had no right and christ cast
them out
and they had to obey do you know that
happened with the two demoniacs
when you read it in the gospels jesus
spoke to them
and they refused to come out that's why
he said
what is your name because he realized
they should have left
instantly and then they were like legion
and he was like okay we can take care of
this there's a whole bunch of you in
there
thousands they had to obey when christ
exchanged lives and that's what he's
telling us today
he imparted his life to the sick the
afflicted and those possessed of demons
he turned away none
who came to receive his healing power
not one
and all of the gospels there was not one
person that came and asked to be healed
and he refused to heal them not one
the bible says all we like sheep have
gone astray
we have turned everyone to our own way
of life
and the lord has laid on him jesus the
iniquities of us
all second corinthians 5 21 says for he
has
made jesus to be sin for us
who knew no sin so that we might be made
the righteousness of god
in him jesus knew that those who
petitioned him for help
had brought disease upon themselves
yet he did not refuse to heal them
and when virtue that word means
dunamis miraculous power
when virtue from christ entered into
these poor souls
they were convicted of sin and many were
healed of their spiritual disease
as well as their physical maladies
the gospel the glad tidings
still possesses the same power and why
should we not today
witness the same results a lot of people
say all you have to do is believe
and then you have another group of
people that say no no no
there's got to be works too if you
honestly believe
there will be works because works can't
be separated from genuine faith
it's like the illustration of love you
you can't just be like i love my wife
and i'm not going to do anything for her
that love will be demonstrated whether
it's washing the dishes
vacuuming the house scrubbing the floor
remembering the anniversary
yeah all those kind of things you that's
just a natural thing you're going to do
for someone that you love them so if you
are in love with jesus you're going to
naturally
desire to do things that you know please
god and you know what
if it's raining outside and i've got my
pj's on
and my and i love my wife and she looks
at me and it's 11 o'clock at night and
she says
i would really like this special treat
that they have at this grocery store and
they're still open for 20 minutes would
you go get it for me
if i genuinely love her even though i
may not
want to go out i do it anyway because
of love i surrender and i sacrifice
my life and my pleasure for my wife
because i love her just like what we
would do for our children
i like this parable about faith and
works what i like is when jesus healed
this
guy that can't walk by the pool of
bethesda
because jesus just said you know take up
whatever you have and then go for what
just just go what if the guy just he
said he believed he said okay i believe
you can heal me but i'm gonna just walk
tomorrow
that's not gonna work right that's right
react
to his belief amen that's a good point
one more uh statement i want to share
with you listen to this and this was
written by a man
um at an old-fashioned camp meeting back
in 1895 his name was
prescott listen to what this man said
you can tell he was inspired by the lord
he says to believe on jesus christ is to
receive christ
and remember christ is the word of god
to believe on christ is to receive
christ not to assent to a creed
but to accept a life not to strive for
the mere
maintenance of certain outward forms
but to become the partaker of the divine
nature
creeds and forms cannot save people from
their sins
terrible is the catalog of those sins of
those
having a form or shape of godliness but
denying the power thereof
christ in us the hope of glory
a new life must be imparted before a man
can
live unto god jesus said except a man be
born from above
he cannot see the kingdom of god
for neither is circumcision anything nor
uncircumcision but a new
creation jesus told us
behold the kingdom of god is within you
my throne is in your heart
i want to reign but not as a monarch on
some
throne that's physical i want to reign
inside of your life
that means if i reign i win every battle
you know we as humans we want to be in
control of our own lives we call it
being on the seat of our own thrones
right
yeah and so we're we're sitting on that
throne and we're like i want to make my
own decisions and i want to do this
right but realistically we then are
slaves to sin and we're just doing the
bidding of
another master right when jesus is
actually saying listen
i i want you to to to allow me onto the
throne of your heart and i will bring
you
up and we can rule together amen on the
throne of that heart so it's like you
get
at the end of the day what you
originally wanted anyway was that that
to
rule your own it's just that you're now
doing it with christ
empowered by him that's right amen
and then prescott says something he said
this experience
of christ reigning within you and having
this new life
depends upon the faith which each one of
us
exercised for ourselves to all who
sincerely pray the prayer
create in me a clean heart the reply
comes
believe ye that i am able to do this
according to your faith be it unto you
for our father has spoken to every one
of us when he said through his son
today you are clean through the word
which i have spoken unto you
that's john 15 verse 3. i mean he
literally says
today and so as you read that
put your name in there yeah it's not a
recipe it's not follow steps one through
ten
you know what i mean like there's not a
a a
labyrinth that you need to walk through
to achieve the end of this thing it's
literally take him at his word
and and you know what is weird for me
like oh i want to make this simple
because
i believe in god's law i love god's law
do you know why because he said that
jesus said i delight
to do thy will your law is in my heart
well if this
mind and this heart are in me which was
in jesus
then i can say that so when a temptation
comes i go wait a minute
christ is in me god i delight to do thy
will
your law is in my heart so as we speak
his word
claiming it as ours that's how god
dwells and reigns within us
so it's like when when we look at you
know a law we also
have to remember something god's
commands
are promises i never understood that i
can remember when i was a young boy and
i went to school and
and or went to church and they would say
god said thou
shalt not lie thou shalt not commit
adultery
and then one day i was reading and the
lord just
showed me eric this is a promise and i
was like how is that a promise
he said read your name into it i was
like thou shalt not commit adultery and
god was like read your name
into it i was like thou god was like
that's you
it's not them it's you thou i was like
eric wilson thus saith the lord i
promise
you won't commit adultery and i was like
god can't lie i mean he can't lie
so he already promised me that
and you know what's neat the promise was
named jesus christ
he is the word of promise so christ
came and lived my life for me
and gained the victory for me if i would
just
let him in and accept his life as mine
and hide him in your heart that i may
not sin against thee amen
amen anyway we uh
i pray that you guys will will take hold
of the gospel remember the gospel means
glad tidings it means
good news it's not just a set of rules
um and i don't want to go off into
something else but it's like if i had
if i had a friend of mine send their
child over to spend the night at our
house
and and let's say they ate possum off
the road
and i'm like okay you're here at our
house for the summer
we don't eat possum in this house and
the little boy's like i'm mad we always
ate possum when i was at home well now
you're part of a new family
we're teaching you a new way to live and
it actually will give you more life than
the possum will
so it's like that way with god god is
not trying to make
rules to check off so that you can make
it into heaven
he's trying to show you the way that
that we live in heaven
and if we can prepare for that here
heaven will be a joy
so if you're able to or if you have
questions please contact little light
studios
or contact us at isaiah ministries i'll
be happy to mail you
some of the promises of where we got
these and and how they were helped to me
but let us know what we can do to help
don't forget to like subscribe to our
channel and
we'll leave some links in the
description so you can get a hold of
eric wilson if you'd like to
or leave a comment about today's show
we'd love to hear what you have to say
thanks for watching
we'll see you next week
[Music]
you